what's up my name is Samuel leaves I'm
standing right now in Wiggins how do you
get rich in property investment what you
do is you buy the worst house on the
best street and you buy the biggest
house so this house right here is one of
the biggest houses in the street it was
an absolute wreck it was completely run
down and it was bought by one of my good
friends and students Muhammad ullah
she's refurbished it he's making a
killing on this house you're not going
to believe the figures let's go speak to
him let's go find out what he's doing
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
how much should you pay for this 105.
105 Grand and now it's like a quarter of
a million pound house yeah you're gonna
find out why it's so expensive in a
minute because this makes him a fortune
how much of your money did you use to
buy this none of my own money none of
your own money it's never my own money
no
so what's wrong bro
[Music]
my this is this is a proper HMR you like
it mate yes fire doors proper fire door
oh yeah house rules yep love this check
out this kitchen nice so this area this
is communal then this is communal HMO as
you can imagine and HMO stands for what
house of multiple occupancy and how many
rooms have you managed to get out we've
managed to make six bedrooms four with
ensuites the other two have got their
own individual bathrooms as well it's
HMR standards yeah so yeah I've got that
I can do it as uh six months asts as a
HMO anytime but I didn't do that yeah
what I decided to do
was put it on service accommodation as
six individual rooms on a short stay
left
okay by doing that
the the cash flow was a lot better is it
ridiculous it's amazing it's a whole
room
so you bought it for 105 Grand yeah
you've refurbed it into a nice six-bit
HMO yeah so you're doing it room by room
all separate all separate tenants yeah
but on shorts that let's as well it's
like a HMO combined with an essay yeah
how much did the refurb cost
fifty seven thousand at the end how much
profit did you make last month on this
house
five thousand four hundred pounds no you
didn't yes I did oh my God so that's
after everything net
that's Financial Freedom on one deal one
deal
you've made it
and that's like like not even that's
like a winter month as well
I can't believe that bro if you get into
HMO what you've been making like one and
a half Grand that was what the numbers
were saying yeah and I wasn't really
happy with that
holy crap I did this with none of me on
money bridging yeah yeah
um loans and credit cards yeah yeah and
personal loans wow you know on good
rates presumably on great rates so I
bought the house with my loans for for
that 105 Grand and then obviously you
put a penny in I didn't the guy that I
bought the house off after I bought the
house we went for a coffee right and I
was explaining what I was going to do
and he ended up loaning me the money as
well to do the refit
so what so the money that you bought the
house with from loans the seller got
yeah you then contacted him and said you
wanted to tell him what your plans were
yeah he used that low money and reloaned
it to you again to do the refurb so
you've got a free refurb effectively
correct funny how money goes around oh
my goodness so how much did he loan you
it's 30 Grand at first and we needed
another five grand 35 Grand and then he
the three foot in total was only 55.
yeah and what about the other two I know
um it all came to another large credit
cards and bridging and so how are you
going to pay all those people back all
those loans back it all comes back well
we've had the valuation in and now we're
exiting out of the bridge and all the
loans everything's gonna get better so
you're getting a new loan to pay off the
old loans yeah a mortgage a mortgage a
mortgage and now because the house is a
lot more expensive like it's like what
about 250 250. so you're gonna then get
a mortgage to pay off the loan to leave
you with a free house
and you're renting out room by room as I
say is yeah you're a smart kid bro thank
you very much hello from the best let's
go look at some of the rooms come on let
me show you around
that room's taken at the moment
this is a room tip so they're like
little hotel rooms yeah what you've made
them and you know what's really
interesting to in order to stay here
we've been in the northern area we were
around Manchester Stockport Liverpool
hotels are all full Yep they're all
fully booked so you're listing this
presumably on the same places that the
hotels list their own yep rooms Airbnb
booking.com so you're literally these
rooms are on booking.com right now they
sure are yeah and how much are people
paying a night to stay here so
weeknights it's 49 pound plus a 20 pound
cleaning fee okay weekends 59 pounds
plus a 20 pound cleaner that's fair
enough
bargain it's um I'm like the premiering
yeah and like but nicer yeah and you got
on Suites in all the rooms you've got
ensuites we've got um kitchens and the
location is pretty banging locations
absolutely brilliant yeah
um one of the big things for me is about
having it in the right location yeah now
the reason I knew this was the right
locations you're gonna love this it's
because uh 500 yards up the road we've
got a premiering right and they've spent
probably hundreds of thousands of pounds
on their due diligence Market Research
in order to do a Premiere in there
they've spent tens of thousands getting
it just furnished alone and then you've
gone they've done the market research
for me well it's gonna work bang it's
gonna work and it does work it does so
would you say that they're your biggest
competitor I wouldn't say competitor
they're there everybody's making their
uh making their living yeah but when
they're fully booked like we were going
to hotels yesterday they're saying we're
fully booked and they were saying try
this hotel try that hotel yeah yeah the
hotels aren't desperate for people to
rent their rooms people are desperate to
rent the rooms of the hotels yeah
especially the weekend what I've noticed
is people are preferring something like
this then a hotel why so you've got
contractors coming into the area and
didn't need the washing machine they
want the kitchen they want the fridge so
you've got the kitchen the communal area
you've got a key safe outside they can
let themselves in rather have to mess
around and check in check out low-key
say for a digital uh keypad on the door
I went to one hotel yesterday we booked
we got there
the tracking brushes took forever yeah
and then once we'd finished checking in
and going through everything and then
said uh did you get your ID I was like
yeah I got my ID no give me a minute I
was looking for it on my phone it's
about five minutes looking for my phone
I finally found it yeah and I was like
there you go and I went
no we need um a physical copy oh my
freaky I lost it man I'm just like we
need Mo's rooms everywhere I just had
that myself I just had that myself but
guests have actually checked into this
room and they've gone out now oh so this
is actually this is actually booked it
the checking it was three o'clock right
and a new year coming around so
brilliant they phoned up early they said
we're in the area can we check it I said
well I'm filming today but yes you can
they've actually left the stuff
underneath here all right and they said
oh it said on there that we needed a
copy of our driver license I said don't
worry I've seen you face to face you're
all right yeah a bit more flexible
that's what you've got to look at you
you've got to look at your customers you
got to know your customers yeah that's
right
so there's one more room we can go in
yes can we disturb some of the guests
and chat to them directly yeah I'm sure
somebody will come down here yeah yeah
all right so I've put some house rules
and so on check out instructions Wi-Fi
if they need to extend the stay yeah
direct booking data booking it say 15
plus vat
um to a lot of people because I know in
our service accommodation properties we
get a lot of relocators yeah so if
people are looking to move house maybe
they've sold the house yeah that they've
got a few weeks and then they'll stay in
one of my houses within a few weeks
sometimes turns into a few months they
keep extending it they're a guest
correct they've got no tenancy rights
they're paying a premium they're happy
they've got the flexibility they've not
gotta get removal mans it's all
furnished yeah they've got the freaking
Wi-Fi code right there I mean you've got
the I just I just put these up simple
and printed it off and just stuck it on
we will frame them and make them really
nice and so on but it just gives the
general information clean as you go
close windows and lock doors no drug and
no drink or disorderly Behavior smoking
allowed in the garden only yeah pets not
allowed no music Allowed no extra guests
allowed to stay events and party is not
premiered and quiet time from 9pm to 9am
yeah and everybody knows the house rules
as soon as they walk in yeah you know
we've got six rooms there's six
different people to cater for and
everybody's gotten all them rules yeah
although knowing you if they did have a
party you would join in the pie yeah of
course yeah come on take it upstairs
[Music]
for women
[Music]
three four five six these rooms are
occupied at the moment so obviously we
can't go in there but this one's this
one's free yeah for now so come in have
a look at this one what kind of an
occupancy rate do you currently get my
first month I hit an 81 occupancy rate
very good very good
a lot of these bookings with me
self-managing yeah I converted them from
booking.com when they wanted to stay
longer a converted them direct yeah so
that helps massive massively when you
when your customers come and stay
you find out what you need to find out
what kind of customers do you have I've
had Builders here I've had doctors here
I've had nurses here I've had students
here yeah yeah
how long do they typically stay for
um I've had I've got uh a guy there
that's been over a month now don't tell
me about that because we're bump into
him yeah what kind of how long do they
typically stay two weeks four weeks
um oh I've got a 47 day booking it right
as we speak Direct
that's great the beauty of why why is it
so popular why do people stay so long
because I imagine at Premier Inn you'd
only stay there for a night or two
nights yeah why are people staying here
for like weeks and weeks well it's it's
the homely effect it's it's the House
hotel right it's the household you're
cracking the market here bro oh yeah
yeah
it's the new way to book a hotel why why
go to a big chain that don't care that
don't you know how much time do you
spend managing this because you're
managing yourself obviously you're
saving money doing that yeah massively
it's all on my phone I've got my apps
set up right
phone call thank you yeah that's it yeah
I've got the cleaners set up
I've got everybody set up I've got the
young lad that works for me I've said to
him but this is what if the cleaner
doesn't turn up he knows how to clean I
know how to clean you know it's all set
up nicely as every room got a private
entry or private bathroom every room's
got its own bathroom with four four of
the rooms in this building we've got
ensues and two of them have got the
wrong bathroom so I I think personally
everybody likes their own bathroom they
need it they need it if you've not got I
think with the HMO some people might
share but I think if you're doing
service accommodation yeah it's not
illegal but you're gonna get the wrong
type of clientele aren't you if you if
you've got a shared bathroom yeah you're
in a mini mini Hotel so they like their
own bathroom and it yeah it's really
important for the service accommodation
side yeah
um
you know obviously the training that we
did taught us how to do the HMO the
reserves accommodations like all this
was lent yeah training that you provide
and what you've done cleverly is you've
linked some of the strategies so you've
gone through all the HMO training you're
on the academy yeah how's the academy
been by the way yeah it's been brilliant
Academy's you know is one of the best
moves I made in my life you know and did
you use did you use your own money to
join the academy
can they use your own
credit card during the academy got all
the training and then you've used loans
loans credit cards and you've got other
properties going on you just bought one
down the road right I got another one on
the go yeah next one's eight bedroom wow
yeah and talk to me about your plans for
this because this is currently a six
bedroom this is a six people telling me
yeah what are you gonna do well I've got
the opportunity yeah so um make it a
eight bedroom I can put stairs going up
this way and up that way and make
another two bedrooms with dance suites
in up there this this room will extend
out it'll have its own ensuite as well
I'm looking at about a 40 Grand cost to
do that I've I've got
and the thing is because this is
technically a commercial property I mean
once you've had your books for two years
yeah
I mean you're talking about evaluation
you're talking about a quarter of a
million pounds as a bricks and more
evaluation yeah the bricks yeah once you
get commercial
two years books on this place is going
to look amazing Matt can you imagine the
value on this exactly because I think
sometimes people are like there'll be
people in the comments that say there's
no way that's worth that much yeah in
Wigan but no no it made five grand
profit last month exactly
commercial valuations exactly you know
so yeah so you've had a an official
Rick's evaluation on this yeah and
that's it was a a commercial bricks and
mortar no bricks and mortar yeah what
did that coming out that came in at um
250
um and then we've got the commercial
valuation element as well yeah
um you know which is going to be scarily
high it's going to be very nice how much
time do you spend managing this because
there's a lot of people moving in moving
out moving Parts yep lots of moving
Parts I've got a good team I've got the
cleaner cleaner manager there I know on
our on our service accommodation
intensive we talk a lot about
CCTV sound detectors have you done that
yeah no sound detector it's not been
needed CCTV is important yeah have you
got that here yeah where is it it's
downstairs motion detector from do you
sit at home you just watch it sometimes
see what's going on yeah as soon as a
guest comes in I can see him yeah but
the thing is it's all systemized because
they come in it's all you've got your
cleaners yep so they come in man you've
got all your online calendar
synchronized yeah everything's
completely systemized all on the phone
there just go on there there's the app
this is for me business if Evo this is
where I look at all the bookings I mean
diary this is this month's bookings
there you go I like all these lines on
there obviously where are we up to
Saturday to 12th so that's all the
bookings that we've had this was my
beauty of a month there look at all them
bookings
there's my heating I control the heating
and there's my strike payment and Airbnb
so onto my camera
systems in the kitchen shall We
There you go there you go
there's one of the guests there's one of
the guests yeah this is guest of the
month David yeah can we go and chat with
him yeah of course is he a friendly guy
oh he's a brilliant guy yeah
I'm gonna go chat with him yeah
hello
David yes yes my name is Samuel I just
wanted to check in with you bro and see
how you're enjoying I'm doing I'm I'm
helping Muhammad with his marketing all
right and I just wondered if you could
uh tell us about how you've enjoyed just
how long how many nights have you been
here no I've been here doing uh above a
month
when you first came in to stay did you
plan on staying this long no no I think
just I just literally when it's just one
week wow and you just and then I kept
moving it moving it because very
comfortable yeah more is a very great
host
uh the apartment well maintained really
really nice yeah and then more has a
heart and he has an attitude that is
very kind
the guess
um well the guests always love the place
uh every guest that's been here has
raved about it we've got great reviews
on booking.com and Airbnb so yeah I'm
sure I'm sure it's all good it's good
man he's a good guy I've known I've
known Mo for like seven years now oh wow
so um the most very helpful you want to
do this you want to do that you need to
get this and to get that before we hit
it up and here I am yeah that's great
well I really appreciate you know you
allowing us to ask you a few questions
yes wish you all the best in London
thank you so much and uh thank you so
much thank you so much it's good to meet
you thank you
thank you
very happy customer here that's what we
do mate he loves you he's brilliant he
loves you oh he says one of the reasons
that you stayed so long is because of
you yeah customer service customer
service what made you decide to do the
garden like this so we were running out
of money and Maxine and it was like uh
yeah everything's maxed out and it's
like right how can I get this Garden
nice on a budget so I went B and Q and
got these for like nine pound each I
thought right that's good and then I got
three tons of stone yeah and um that was
like 90 pound a bag right and uh the
truck came and we sliced it we put the
membrane down first and uh we got we got
it done on a budget how much did this
cost to get this looking under a grand
under a ground it's also low maintenance
right yeah this is no I've got to worry
about cutting the grass right now this
is Garden hack me so Financial Freedom
from one deal absolutely incredible bro
final words of wisdom or advice for
people wanting to get started in
property you've got to go for it you
just gotta go for it
um it's hard it's not easy nothing's
ever easy if it was easy everybody would
be doing it you got challenges I won't
even call it hard it's challenges right
you've got it's like hurdle jumping I
keep jumping over them hurdles when the
challenges come and just get it done
um
even I was surprised at the numbers on
this right I was like buzzing over it I
was waiting for that month to end so we
can add it all up yeah and I was just
buzzing over it
um now I know what's what's doable you
know scale it up now oh yeah yeah I've
got another next one in the pipe yeah
and you've also been packaging and
selling deals yep yep deal Source in a
way yeah deal sourcing away me and Mark
we work work together and yeah we get
deals for our investors as well and yeah
it's win-win for everybody amazing yeah
2019 I started the journey
um you know in learning about property
and I'm so glad I'll learn about
property because without that training I
wouldn't have known what I've known to
be able to do what I've done you see and
like anything you can be anything in
life so long as you learn about it so
long as you get the right training for
the right people and be around the right
people as well yeah
um vital vital and uh yeah smashed it
well I appreciate your business man I'll
tell you something as well it's about
getting the right training but it's also
about putting in the work oh yeah and
getting through those hurdles yeah and
you've done that like crazy Moe's an
absolute rock star so Financial Freedom
from one deal although this is not your
own idea you've got a whole bunch of
stuff going on yeah I have yeah but what
I'd say is if you want to do the same
connect join the community I'm going to
leave a link in the description where
you can come down spend a day with me at
the property investors crash course it's
one pound get booked on and we'll see
you next time